what do you do when you don't have the
awareness when it's just that that fear
or that reaction is just so subconscious
that you're you don't even realize that
you're holding yourself back constantly
how do you drink free of that is
awareness the first step you you talk
about it with somebody else you describe
it to somebody else I can't whatever I
don't whatever and they say well why is
that a problem baba Baba bong and you
suddenly realize that because they're
not so identify I do with it they can
easily see through it what is it they're
called mastermind groups the whole theme
of a mastermind group is when somebody
is not identified with it personally
they can see it more clearly so
understand i happen to be able to create
my own mastermind group with myself so
there's Michael who this Michael who
that Michael who the other Michael the
other they're all these different parts
inside of me I've grown accustomed to
having a relationship with so I'm
suddenly discovering stuff that I
couldn't discover on my own the Michael
who the Michael who the Michael Liu you
follow what I'm saying this might sound
terribly confusing to everybody but the
reality is it is a need to be confusing
all you got to do is just let go of all
this crap that you're hanging on to and
just pursue it pursue what well it's
very simple by the course as you buy the
course I'll take you through the process
step one step two step three step four
etc and we'll make complete unavoidable
sense to you and when that happens then
it's going to be yes but yes but yes but
it always ends up with yes but hear me
always but you understand now that
you're aware of that creature yes but
the one who says no without saying no
but gives you the reasons why saying no
makes such great sense the yes bud the
spud is in every single one of you
you're saying it right now yeah but yeah
but yeah but yeah that's good Michael
but yeah but yeah but every single time
somebody does that all he or she is
doing is providing themselves with an
excuse to not act period so when a said
come over here to see Sam well Hayes y
ba ba ba and is it yep okay well let's
do it who the hell knows what's going to
happen in fact had I not gone to that
meeting I wouldn't be talking to you
today I'd be framing houses in Mendocino
County or something to understand I mean
just get that and the minute you get
that you'll understand that all of this
is already here for every single one of
you you just don't see it and you don't
see it because your enclosed in this
prison your mind has enclosed you in a
prison that will not allow you to see
outside of it I'm opening the doors to
your prison you're free now what I love
it and I love that you mastermind with
yourself too i think that's interesting
my mastermind is better than any master
mind it's ever existed on on the earth
you understand I could sit down duck but
all these people and I discover that in
fact there are more solutions inside me
then I've ever discovered outside of me
now that sounds terribly narcissistic
but it really isn't I'm suggesting that
rather than needing to go out and
already within you are the answers to
questions you haven't even asked yet
it's knowing what the questions are
that's most important because somebody
could ask me a question and satins to me
all the time in the Dreaming room for
example or even on calls like this last
me a question and I'll give them a
completely different answer to a
different question my wife always says
to me Michael you're always answering
questions they never asked you I said no
I'm answering the question they should
have asked me they just didn't know what
the question was so having said that